[Musique]
a paris le palais des sports va
accueillir louis armstrong et son
orchestre de jazz
après la boxe et le cirque en outre
jean-louis barrault louis seigner et
georges wilson c'est à dire le théâtre
de france la comédie française et le tnp
vont ils jouer hamlet le bourgeois
gentilhomme et ubu roi
[Musique]
le cinéma lui a consacré comme une
valeur sûre la jeune vedette perdait
pradier 18e lauréate du prix suzanne
bianchetti que pierre laroche lui a
remis au nom des auteurs de films la
pauvrété si ému qu'il a fallu sécher ses
larmes
[Musique]
la littérature policière quant à elle a
annexé un nouvel auteur non pas
l'académicien marcel achard venus
simplement en connaisseur mais le
colonel rémy le prix du quai des
orfèvres fondé par jacques catineau est
allé en effet au monocle noir premier
roman policier du célèbre historien de
la france résistante
[Musique]
si chaque génération d'enfants à ses
héros préférés ce ne sont pas toujours
les mêmes et l'on peut se demander en ce
mois de décembre quels personnages vont
dominer les rêves d'enfants
ainsi est née l'idée d'un référendum à
l'échelon le moins élevé c'est à dire
parmi les moins de 15 ans et l'on a
abandonné les étalages d'une librairie à
la passion d'une quarantaine d'enfants
oui
[Musique]
perplexité
si si ou legrand sip
[Musique]
on savait que l'époque était passé de
l'engouement pour les malheurs de sophie
ou le général du rpt à keane qui ont
fait rêver nos enfances allait-on leur
préférer les conquérants interplanétaire
l'heure du choix était arrivé la pile la
plus haute aller nettement désigné un
héros qui a depuis longtemps fait ses
preuves
ivanhoé
il faut donc croire que les modes ne
change pas si vite
[Musique]
la vie de bureau n'est pas ce qu'a 20
peuple pense elle comporte aussi ses
risques à petit cause dit un proverbe
grand effet c'est ainsi qu'il importe de
ne pas laisser traîner les fils
téléphoniques
il va de soi que sur le chantier à l'
usine les risques que comportent les
chutes sont souvent plus grave pour une
cause aussi anodine qu'un objet oublié
un seul puissant et rouler des tonneaux
devient un exercice périlleux
si bien que toutes sortes de précautions
d'apparence banale ont leur importance
répondre du sable mesures efficaces mais
provisoire procéder à un nettoyage
complet ou ce qui est mieux prévoir lors
de la construction un sol grillagé
antidérapant éviter l'alpinisme en usine
par l'installation d'un dispositif
adéquat
supprimez les escaliers gruissan chaque
année les chutes de plain pied cause
deux cent mille accidents dont la
plupart pourraient être évités c'est le
même nombre qu'on enregistre pour des
accidents de la route
or ces chutes si elles sont comiques
parfois ne sont pas toujours inoffensive
[Musique]
l'homme fort à léopoldville c'est
aujourd'hui le président kasavubu que le
colonel mobutu était venu accueillir à
son retour de new york où l'onu a
reconnu son pouvoir soldats en armes
pour lui faire accueil et foule
enthousiaste sur le chemin qui l'a
conduit en vie
[Applaudissements]
c'était aussi des soldats en armes qui
attendaient monsieur lumumba dans ce
même léopoldville né dans une atmosphère
tout différent
m
[Musique]
arrêté alors qu'il tentait de gagner
stanleyville l'ancien président du
conseil est désormais aux mains de ses
adversaires
[Musique]
ici nouakchott c'est au milieu des
sables la capitale de la toute neuve
république islamique de mauritanie
capital émouvante dans sa réalité
puisqu'elle ne montre que peu de mur
qu'elle ne compte que deux mille
habitants et qu'à défaut de passer elle
ne se bâtit que sur l'avenir est bien
celle à verser quelques murs blancs que
sont venus quelques milliers d'hommes
mais c'est beaucoup quelques milliers
dans un pays qui n'en comptent que six
cent vingt mille réparties sur un
territoire double de celui de la france
la mauritanie célébrer son indépendance
à l'assemblée nationale le président de
la république monsieur moktar ould
daddah a proclamé l'indépendance de son
pays devant 13 cents invités parmi
lesquels la ga quand les présidents du
sénégal du niger de la haute volta du
dahomey de la côte d'ivoire monsieur
michel debré et monsieur masmoudi ainsi
la mauritanie devient le 15e état de
l'afrique noire naguère française à
accéder à cette majorité à laquelle la
france les a conduits et si le veto de
l'urss empêche aujourd'hui la mauritanie
d'être présente à l'onu il n'en reste
pas moins qu'elle est devenue à la fois
un état et une patrie
[Musique]
les américains font école les allemands
en effet s'intéresse désormais au saut
au tremplin élastique sport qui a vu le
jour outre atlantique
et c'est à francfort que se déroule le
premier championnat d'allemagne auquel
participent également les femmes les
athlètes masculins sont beaucoup plus
audacieux
[Musique]
si vous craignez le vertige il vaut
peut-être mieux pour fermiers les yeux
[Musique]
là ça va beaucoup mieux c'est
l'opérateur qui avait le coeur sens ce
qui n'est pas le cas de cette athlète au
fait il ne sait peut-être plus comment
faire pour s'arrêter si tu m'aimes pour
faire du ski cette année pas besoin
d'aller bien loin pour l'entraînement
cet appareil délicatement posée sur une
descente de lit est suffisant c'est très
sérieux avec ce système on acquiert la
souplesse des chevilles et la puissance
des molettes c'est du moins jean vuarnet
le champion olympique qui l'affirment
[Musique]
est maintenant à nous les champs de
neige terminus porte de versailles cette
année les champs de neige se font en
mousse plastifié décidément on n'arrête
pas le progrès
bien sûr il manque l'air pur de la
montagne mais c'est peut-être aussi le
moyen d'éviter d'attraper froid
[Musique]
l'élu yorkais sont aussi paresseux que
les parisiens c'est fastidieux les
voyages un peu de neige artificielle sur
les pentes kazan et de central park et
nous voilà transportés à squaw valley je
conjure apparaît beaucoup plus doué pour
la natation que pour le ski
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après des résultats aussi probants on
comprend maintenant pourquoi ces
champions n'ose pas se rendre à la
montagne les footballeurs rémois maillot
français qu'une autre blanche joue à
quitte ou double devant le racing club
de paris les rémois qui sont les forts
en thème du football français mènent des
opérations tambour battant
le football n'est pas à un paradoxe près
et c'est sans doute pour cela que le
racing marque le premier but par
l'intermédiaire de ven sam son nouvel
ailier gauche connaître pas en reste
sauvage également diego chez également
nouveaux joueurs dans son équipe égalise
pourquoi
les rémois qui connaissent leur football
sur le bout des deux pieds vont prendre
l'aventage sur cette action de glowacki
de rémois à la réception pour taper dans
le ballon c'est 3 kg anthony tape dans
le ballon mais fontaine lui ne trouve
bien qu'à volontairement que la tête du
gardien de but parisien
résultat un nouveau but pour les rémois
mais aussi le bol parisien à l'hôpital
encore un paradoxe eux sont contents les
parisiens qui égalise
[Applaudissements]
le match n'est pas fini pour autant puis
anthony numéro 10 et fontaine numéro 900
donnent à coeur joie
fontaine se rappelle qu'il a été le
meilleur buteur de la coupe du monde il
maintenant qu'un troisième très joli
bout et coup surtout il redistribue deux
autres à ses partenaires qui gagne le
match par 5 à 3 reims a encore une
chance d'être champion de france cette
année
[Musique]